a bit of silence says Australians pay
tribute to the queen
this would be
the most fitting Memorial
to a magnificent life of service to
others
May Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth II rest
in Eternal peace
but not all Australians have embraced
the national day of mourning instead
protesters in state capitals have oyster
opposition demanding recognition of the
suffering that indigenous people endured
during British colonization the monarchs
representative in Australia has
acknowledged that the Queen's death has
prompted a broader debate about the
country's Colonial past I'm conscious
and respect that the response of many
First Nations Australians is shaped by
our Colonial history and broader
reconciliation Journey
that is a journey we as a nation must
complete
the tent Embassy is an
is a landmark represented
pain for Aboriginal rights this year
marks the 50th Anniversary since it was
erected but the death of the queen has
reignited the movement once again
it's also sparked conversations about
Australia's future under the monarchy an
opinion poll this week suggests less
than half the population is in favor of
becoming a republic I'm personally
supportive of a republic and I think
um but I'm not quite sure having seen
the outpouring of grief and support for
the queen that we're quite ready but you
know I think there's a lot of Education
to do between now and then it's part of
our history and I think we've learned
that we've let go of History before and
we shouldn't let go again
the Prime Minister has ruled out a
referendum for now noting it's not the
right time for such a debate Sarah Clark
Al Jazeera Canberra